hey what is up everybody it's animac
here for anime uproar and it's all
finally being revealed the National
Treasure of marijua imusama's true power
the ancient weapon Uranus the king of
the world zebic God Valley laughtail Joy
boy it's all connected the end of wano
has given us an avalanche of massive
game-changing reveals and all the pieces
of the giant one-piece puzzle are
finally coming together I don't think
that many people realize what the reveal
of imusama's Island destroying weapon
means for the ending of one piece this
might have just spoiled the entire end
of the story so let's break it down if
you guys enjoy our one piece content and
you want to see more in the future leave
a quick like and comment right now to
help with the YouTube algorithm and if
you haven't taken the time to subscribe
already do me a favor and click that
subscribe button and then also the bell
and select the option that says all it
is completely live free and it really
means a lot on YouTube before we get
into it a quick thank you to one punch
man the strongest for sponsoring this
video you guys know I'm a huge fan of
one punch man and I am super excited for
the launch of the brand new mobile RPG
one punch man the strongest the game
allows you to relive the most iconic and
hilarious scenes in the anime but you
can also get over 60 in-game characters
including the heroes and villains in
order to create your own Ultimate Team
seriously you can put like genos and
cablante on the same team which is
freaking hilarious and the game features
the voices of the original Japanese
anime cast it's like reliving the anime
but this time you're in control the
launch event is happening right now and
there are over 1 million
pre-registrations already new players
who log in consecutively during the
first week will be able to get over 50
draws as as well as other rewards
including an old hand Avatar and
Apprentice frame the A-Class hero eidon
and a free character of your choice so
what are you waiting for dive into the
one punch man Universe right now one
punch man the strongest is available on
Android and iOS and if you download it
right now you will be directly
supporting this channel click the top
Link in the description or use the QR
code on screen and don't forget to use
my promo code OPM TS fight alongside
saitama and be a hero for fun finally
this video will contain One Piece manga
spoilers so please proceed with caution
you have been warned ever since the
mysterious being known as eem or imusama
was first introduced in chapter 906 of
the manga fans have been wondering who
this being is and what are his or her
true intentions we've also been
wondering how powerful this being
actually is in terms of raw physical
power and how this figure may impact the
the story as a whole especially as we
approach the final arcs and the climax
of the entire series emu's reveal was so
shocking because after all that talk
about an empty throne and the fact that
there was no single King who presided
over the world government we suddenly
learned that someone does sit on the
empty Throne someone does hold the
position of king of the world but the
vast majority of the world just doesn't
realize it emu is a being before whom
even the gorosei must bow down and
nobody besides the very upper echelon of
the world government is even aware of
imusama's existence and yet it is clear
that imusama is the one who really
decides what the world government should
and shouldn't do and who or what will be
erased from history before the
game-changing events of chapter 1060 we
knew very little about imusama and his
or her true power we knew that emu
enjoys spending time in the garden and
playing with butterflies you know all
the normal things that extremely
peaceful and non violent people do we
also knew that imusama seems to have a
special interest in four people Luffy
Blackbeard Vivi and shirahoshi it is
implied that imusama's weapon of choice
is a saber because eem had seemingly
used a saber to pierce through a photo
of shirahoshi finally emu is in
possession of a giant straw hat which
has been locked away inside a massive
freezing vault in marijua during the
revery Arc we saw imusama sitting down
on the empty Throne as the gorosei bowed
down and asked him to tell them the name
of the light that needed to be
extinguished from history after that
imusama disappeared from the story but
he or she definitely didn't disappear
from the collective consciousness of the
one-piece fandom because in the years
that followed we've all been theorizing
left and right about eem's true identity
the full extent of im's powers and his
or her true intentions and motivations
would emu Sama be the final villain of
the story the last boss that Luffy has
to take down down on his way to becoming
the pirate king or was emu more of a
political figure like someone who
doesn't possess real physical power but
maintains control over the world with
the help of the institutional might of
the world government well that question
was definitely answered in chapter 1060
of the story and that is when the entire
fandom exploded as eem's devastating
true power was finally revealed leading
up to that chapter we learned that king
cobra was murdered during the reverie
and his daughter Vivi disappeared Sabo
and the revolutionaries were being
blamed for Cobra's murder as it occurred
during their successful infiltration of
marijua and presumably Vivi was
kidnapped by the revolutionaries after
they managed to kill Cobra and rescue
Kuma but we all know that this is fake
news the revolutionaries did declare war
on the celestial dragons they did
infiltrate marijua and they did rescue
Kuma however they would never have
killed Cobra who was a noble ruler and
law loved by his people and they never
would have kidnapped Vivi we then see
flame Emperor Sabo attempting to contact
the Revolutionary command he makes the
call without using a white transponder
snail meaning that the call can be
traced and that is exactly what the Navy
does they traced the call and they relay
that information to the gorosei and
imusama immediately Sabo is located
inside the kingdom of La Lucia one of
the eight countries that recently
rebelled against the world government
and joined the revolutionaries during
the call Sabo tells dragon that he
wasn't the one who assassinated king
cobra but while he was in marijua he saw
something terrible he saw IM sitting on
the empty throne and he had managed to
escape marijua with that important piece
of information but just asab was about
to reveal that the empty throne in
Pangea Castle is not actually empty that
there is indeed a king of the world even
though there was never supposed to to be
the communication is cut off those
Marines who intercepted the message are
informed by their superiors that they
didn't intercept any messages from the
kingdom of La Lucia today and that is
because the kingdom of the Lucia never
existed in the first place the sky over
La Lucia is extremely dark at this point
in time as if some giant object was
hovering right above the kingdom and
then out of that giant object 16 massive
energy beams or like laser beams shoot
out and destroy the entire Kingdom of
Lucia in a matter of seconds suddenly
removing every trace of its existence in
a single massive sphere of Destruction
it is implied that eem is in control of
this mysterious flying weapon and that
the weapon was sent there for the
specific purpose of destroying lulucia
judging by what the god of say say it
seems that the Lucia was going to be
destroyed anyway and this was the the
light that needed to be extinguished
from history Sabo was just unlucky
because he ended up on an island that
was already slated for Destruction and
so his attempt to reveal imusama's
existence only hastened that destruction
the implication of course is that Sabo
and every single person present on the
Lucia was destroyed in the blast now
personally I think that it only looked
like the people of Lucia were killed but
they had already managed to be evacuated
to a nearby Island and they simply
witnessed the destruction from afar
that's because Sabo likely overheard
that La Lucia was about to be destroyed
when imusama revealed which light needed
to be extinguished from history back
inside the throne room during the
reverie he overheard this at the exact
same time that he learned of emu's
existence Sabo then orchestrated the
call to dragon in order to make the
world government think that he and
everyone on Lucia had died after all
there is a reason why he didn't use a
white trans Ponder snail he was
expecting the call to be intercepted but
regardless of whether Sabo died or not
then he certainly did not the power of
this flying weapon which destroyed the
Lucia in seconds is an absolutely
massive reveal first up what is this
weapon is this the ancient weapon Uranus
which was named after the Greek deity
who was the literal personification of
the sky in Greek mythology that would
certainly make sense since Poseidon is
the god of the sea and Poseidon in one
piece is related to the sea pluton is
the god of the underworld and the Earth
and pluton in one piece is hidden
beneath wano and so Uranus being a
weapon associated with the sky clearly
fits the pattern also is this the secret
treasure of marijua that treasure that
doflamingo talked about as something
that would allow whoever controlled it
to rule the entire world if the National
Treasure of marijua is a flying weapon
that can destroy an entire Island in
seconds then yeah it is definitely
something that could be used to rule
over the world so it is highly likely
that this weapon is the treasure that
dolphy was talking about and as Artur
from the library of ahara Channel
pointed out dolphy's own ultimate attack
is known as the 16 holy assassins
bullets which could be a direct
reference to the 16 energy beams or
laser beams that emu's weapon emits as
it destroys an island finally is this
the same weapon that destroyed God
Valley and wiped it completely out of
existence and out of recorded history
sengoku couldn't really talk openly
about what really happened to God Valley
but we know that he didn't say that the
island was destroyed with a buster call
so to me it is clear that in order to
hide the truth of what really happened
at God Valley eem used this exact weapon
to extinguish it from history in the
same way that La Lucia was just
extinguished from history so now that we
know that him possesses such an
incredibly powerful weapon possibly the
ancient weapon Uranus itself the
question then becomes what is eem's true
identity and what role will this weapon
play in the remainder of the one piece
Story one theory about eem's identity is
that he is actually rocks the zebek
zebek had always wanted to become king
of the world and since that is the
precise title that eem seems to hold
this theory states that zebek actually
wanted God Valley but he faked his own
death and then destroyed the island in
order to hide the fact that he became
the king of the world I did an entire
video on this Theory so I won't get into
any more details here I will just link
the video in the description if you want
to check it out but there is another
theory that is more popular the theory
that eem is actually an immortal being a
being that has been around ever since
the void Century that Frozen straw hat
at marijua actually belonged to the
original Joy boy and eem keeps it there
as a sort of souvenir of his or her
victory over the ancient Kingdom eem's
possession of the sky weapon could also
provide a clue for why the ancient
Kingdom lost in the first place since
the pornoglyphs seem to talk a lot about
the three ancient weapons and since the
ancient Kingdom created these
pornoglyphs it is reasonable to assume
that the ancient Kingdom also created
the ancient weapons however if eem
really controls one of the three ancient
weapons then maybe eem managed to use
one of the ancient Kingdom's most
powerful weapons against them in fact
maybe eem was once someone who fought
alongside the ancient Kingdom but then
he or she betrayed the ancient Kingdom
stole Uranus and used it to become the
king of the world at any rate all of
this may also give us a massive clue
about the true nature of laughtail
something that I didn't actually think
about until my editor axel beats pointed
it out the red pornoglyphs also known as
the road Panic glyphs are the load
panoglyphs are said to reveal the
location of laughtail the final Island
on the grand line the idea is that if
you know where all four of them are
located the point in the middle between
all four of them will reveal laughtail's
location to put it simply if you connect
all four pone glyphs with two diagonal
lines that form an X the middle of the X
will reveal laughtail's location the x
marks the spot but here's the problem
one of the road poneoglyphs is located
on zou and zo is located on top of
zunesha and zunesha is a giant elephant
that is always moving so how can you
determine the center point between all
four Pony glyphs if one of them is
always moving it doesn't make sense
unless laughtail itself is a moving
Target an island that actually moves the
reason why is is forced to keep moving
is so that the location of the paniclyph
on Soul can continue to correspond with
the location of laughtail and that
fourth panoglyph the one that is
currently missing may also be on the
move for this exact reason and if
laughtail is a moving Island then this
would explain why it was never destroyed
by eem's weapon despite the fact that it
contains information that could destroy
the world government and despite the
fact that eem has had 800 years to find
it and destroy it eem's weapon has not
been used on a moving Target it wasn't
used to attack a pirate Fleet or
anything like that it was only used to
destroy stationary targets such as La
Lucia and probably God Valley which
could imply that it needs to be
stationary to function and it may also
need time to charge and discharge its
payload all of which seems to be done
while the weapon is standing still so
the Epic reveal of eem's weapon May may
have revealed not only the third ancient
weapon Uranus not only the National
Treasure of marijua but also the
treacherous truth about the ancient war
and the true nature of laughtail and for
those of you who believe that Luffy will
eventually break through the red line in
order to unite the entire world and
create the all blue well eem just gave
you a way to achieve this if anything
can destroy the red line it is this
flying weapon with potentially some help
from the other two ancient weapons
Poseidon and pluton after chapter 1060 a
lot of people have focused in on emu's
strength as compared to the other
powerful characters in the story but it
seems that a lot of people are missing
just how badly Oda may have spoiled the
entire ending of One Piece the three
ancient weapons the fall of the red line
the truth about the ancient war the
moving island of laughedale all of the
pieces are now falling into place and as
this is the final Saga of the story we
can expect the reveals to just keep
coming after 25 years it's all finally
starting to make sense and I can't wait
to see how it all ends what do you guys
think is eem's weapon the ancient weapon
Uranus is laughtail a moving Island and
that is why eem was unable to destroy it
for 800 years despite having a weapon
that can destroy Islands in seconds is
Sabo really dead again no he's not but
anyway don't forget to leave your
feedback down in the comments below I
always love hearing from you if you
enjoy our one piece content and you want
to see more in the future leave a quick
like and comment right now and if you
haven't taken the time to subscribe yet
do me a big favor and make this the
video that you subscribe and hit that
notification Bell to turn on all
notifications you can also hit me up on
Twitter and Instagram at anime uproar
thanks again to one punch man the
strongest for sponsoring this video
check them out the link in the
description as always thank you guys so
much for watching and until next time
see us peace Cowboys